Emily Thornbury is here for us
for labor this morning what do you make
of what should happen to shamama begum
well there's a judicial process going on
we will hear from the courts at 10
o'clock and I just hope that whatever
decision is made
um we can now put this matter behind us
and move on we can't influence the judge
of course though can we what's your view
well
I personally think that the priority for
me would have always been the children
you know these women go out to Syria and
they've had children that they were
British citizens at the time they've had
children these children are now
stateless and the International
Community does need to work out what the
future of these clearly innocent
children are going to be that would have
always been my priority I also think if
it had been me I think that I probably
would have wanted to bring shamima bacon
back to Britain so that she could face
charges for the offenses that she's
clearly committed the then Home
Secretary um Sergeant recently said if
we knew what he knew she should never be
allowed back in this country because she
is a risk surely I don't know can we not
push if that is the case can she not be
tried and put in jail if that proves to
be the case
well that's what I'm that's what I've
said I mean I think that I think that
you know on the face of it she's clearly
committed offenses I think she should
have been brought back here and and
faced justice but you know the the
government has taken another course and
they've decided to strip her of a
British nationality and and uh as far as
I can see she although I think she can
claim Bangladeshi citizenship she is
effectively largely stateless
um in a refugee settlement but as I say
more important than than her is other
children are the children of these women
and what's going to happen to them
I believe if she did go to Bangladesh
she would face the death penalty but
again that's speculation at this stage
she talked to me about the Northern
Ireland uh protocol what are we going to
do to sort out what was the Border going
to go I know that labor said it will
support the government whatever
um where do you want to see the Border
can I start K by just saying that when I
when I first did prime minister's
questions the very first question I
asked was what was going to happen if we
left the European Union to the Border
um between between Northern Ireland and
the rest of of Europe
um and you know if we left a customs
Union how is that going to work because
it isn't an easy answer right and I
didn't get an answer and I think we're
still struggling to find one I think
that clearly you know everybody watching
this program knows the background you
know we had a prime minister who claimed
he had an oven ready deal he said that
he had a solution he clearly didn't have
a solution it clearly doesn't work and
what's happening until it was a
temporary solution oh all right a
temporary oven ready solution right well
if only he'd spelled that out
um but instead what we need to have is
we need to find a permanent solution it
is difficult and it is holding up the I
mean the also the deal that we came to
with the European Union people will
remember were signed on Christmas Eve it
wasn't a complete deal it needed to have
further negotiation not just on Northern
Ireland but actually there's a whole
load of other things we can see by the
way that our trade has gone down with
the rest of Europe that there are all
kinds of hurdles that British business
absolutely needs to get cleared out the
way and we can't do that without
improving our relationship with the
European Union we can't do that without
sorting out Northern Ireland so we need
to sort out Northern Ireland now I know
that care has been to Northern Ireland a
number of times spoken to business in
Northern Ireland who have had a number
of suggestions which they have been
putting forward both to government and
to the opposition but our position is
this if it's a deal that's in the
interests of our country the Prime
Minister can rely on us to support him
he doesn't have to negotiate with these
head bangers in the Tory party who I
don't know what they want but whatever
they want it's not in the in the
country's interest we need to come to a
solution and the government can if it's
in the interest of the country rely on
us so you know stop wasting your time
negotiating with with some of these
people and just move on and move on with
with a sensible group of people in
Parliament who want to see our economy
looked after and be able to walk into
the future and the leave this brexit
nightmare behind us where does labor
want the border to be
I think we need to be fairly fluid about
it I mean I think that we can't have
Northern Ireland cut off from the rest
of the United Kingdom that's contrary to
the north to the to the Good Friday
agreement but equally you know in the
northern in the Good Friday agreement
there was to be a more fluid border
between North and South so you know this
is a question of subtlety and and proper
negotiation and not just catchphrases
and there needs to be as I say give and
take on both sides and a kind of
subtlety that we are up for and we are
up for supporting the government on and
the reason the government is stumbling I
think is because of the hardliners
within their own party I'm still not
sure where you think the Border should
be well I think there shouldn't be a
border between Northern Ireland and the
rest of the United Kingdom I think that
you know the United Kingdom includes
Northern Ireland but I think that there
needs to be a softer border between
between Northern Ireland and the south
of Ireland because that is a very
important part of the of the Good Friday
agreement
so you do think the Border should be a
land border
well there is a land border but the
point is is in practice how does it work
so in practice how does it impinge on
the lives of people living on either
side of the border for the it's very
important for peace that that is as soft
as possible and as discreet as possible
but clearly there will be a border I was
speaking to
um Lord hey
um who of course used to be a labor
Northern Ireland secretary he was
suggesting that we should have red and
green roots are going into Northern
Ireland across the Irish sea
I don't really understand what that
means
I mean it'd be interesting I mean it's
always interesting to hear what Peter
says but I don't know I don't know about
it listen listen we're not involved in
these negotiations right I wish we were
if we had been involved in these
negotiations because no prime minister
might need to rely on listen the Prime
Minister knows that he can rely on us if
he comes up with a solution which is in
the interest of all that's why I'm
trying to find out what you think and
the solution is and and and we are
saying that you know we we understand
through the through the we haven't been
told officially but through the winks
and nudges we understand that there is a
an agreement that has been come to at
least an outline from what we understand
of it it sounds like it's the it's the
right way forward he doesn't need to
worry he will get it through part two
because we are we understand that there
are a series of agreements that will be
made so that for example they will be
able to be
um items that won't need to be checked
on the border but there can be
agreements in advance of knowing what
items there are and whether they will
will be acceptable and they will be able
to flow through more naturally and how
you get to those sorts of agreements is
something that as I say is subject to
the negotiation that's been going on but
with a softening of that border can
happen will happen and we need to make
sure that there's still some security
there
the fundamental Security is to ensure
that we continue to have peace in
Ireland that's the most important thing
it's 25 years I think almost since the
Northern Ireland agreement exactly was
first signed exactly and we want to be
able to celebrate that we want to be
able to celebrate that by having got
this matter sorted out in advance of
Good Friday you know we want to have the
American president coming over and
celebrating with us 25 years and despite
Britain leaving the European Union the
because of course the northern Irish
agreement was also based on the idea of
everybody being in the European Union so
there needs to be a bit of give and take
in relation to this but where there's
Goodwill there's a way
do you think the agreement will be this
week
I think it might be
um but as I say it depends whether he
hears us when we say don't worry about
trying to get your head bangers to agree
you've got us
how interesting I almost forgot to ask
you about uh Crackdown on drugs that's
what you wanted to talk about today I
wanted to talk particularly actually
about something which we discovered
recently and in answer to questions that
I'd asked to the attorney general which
is that that the number of prosecutors
in the grand prosecution service has
gone down by 25 in a year which is
really frightening because if we don't
have enough prosecutors then that simply
is going to add to the backlog of cases
within the courts and the longer that
cases go on you know before they
actually get to be heard the more likely
they are to collapse particularly cases
like rape and particularly cases where
you need to rely on Witnesses in things
like drugs cases you so we need to make
so so when I found this out we were
amazed and and wrote back and checked
but we understand these numbers are
right and they because they can't
attract people into the crown
prosecution service and when they do
they can't keep them so we've come up
with a solution which is that there are
things called associate prosecutors and
they have a lot of experience and and
expertise in crime and what we've said
is in a kind of all hands to the pump
type way let them do the job of full
prosecutors at least in the interim and
when we think probably in the long term
and so that we can we can fill these
gaps and we can really push on with
getting criminal cases into the courts
and dealt with quickly and properly
because the backlog in the courts is
getting worse and worse they've had
they've got targets for Cutting Edge
they set up a Target last year of
cutting cases I think by seven thousand
they've actually gone up you know our
criminal justice system is in complete
crisis from from police officer not
having enough police officers catching
enough criminals to them being processed
and being dealt within the courts and
then into the criminal justice system
out on the other side no and it's been
overlooked for far too long and there's
a series of problems but this one in
particular I wanted to highlight today
which is that we've lost 25 percent of
our prosecutors from the crown
prosecution service in a year